digamos que hay un par de hierbas que
las personas creen que ayudan a prevenir
la influenza para probar esto esperamos
a la temporada de influenza y
seleccionamos aleatoriamente a personas
para tratar diferentes grupos lo sabemos
ya sea en un grupo tomando la hierba uno
el segundo grupo tomando la hierba 2 o
el tercer grupo en donde toman un
placebo si ustedes no saben lo que es un
placebo es algo que toma el paciente o
la persona que está participando y que
le hace creer que está tomando medicinas
que se les dice que le puede ayudar pero
realmente no hace nada podría ser una
pastillita de azúcar algo que solamente
aparenta ser medicina y las personas
mejoran a esto se le llama efecto
placebo en donde a las personas se les
dice que se le está dando medicina
cuando realmente no es nada y aún así
mejoran así que esto de aquí podría ser
una pastillita de azúcar una cantidad
muy pequeña de azúcar que no les puede
afectar en nada
y aquí tenemos una tabla
qué se le llama tabla de contingencia
tabla de contingencia
y esta tabla contiene por cada grupo el
número de personas que se enfermaron y
el número de personas que no se
enfermaron y de esta tabla podemos
calcular el total de personas en cada
grupo
en el grupo 1 tenemos un total de 120 en
el grupo 2 tenemos un total de 140 y en
el grupo del placebo tenemos un grupo de
120 también podemos calcular el número
total de personas que se enfermaron y el
número total de personas que no se
enfermaron tenemos 20 más 30 50 50 más
treinta igual a 80 y de los que no se
han enfermado son 100
+ 110 210 más 90 son 300
y el total de personas aquí es de 380
tanto de esa columna como de este
renglón y haciendo un lado a esto vamos
a ver que podemos utilizar de esta tabla
de contingencia y usaremos nuestro
conocimiento sobre la tabla cuadrada
para llegar a alguna conclusión
denunciemos una hipótesis la hipótesis 0
dice que las hierbas no hacen nada vamos
a asumir y hacer más espacio aquí con la
hipótesis 0 que las hierbas
a hacer nada
y tenemos otra hipótesis alternativa que
vamos a llamar h 1 en donde las hierbas
si hacen algo
las hierbas si hacen algo y de hecho no
me interesa si es que de verdad están
mejorando incluso podrían aumentar su
probabilidad de enfermarse
no estamos probando si son buenas o no
sino si están haciendo algo o nuestras
haciendo nada y para probar estas
hipótesis vamos a asumir la hipótesis
cero hipótesis cero
y dado que estamos asumiendo esto vamos
a calcular cuál es la probabilidad de
encontrar datos como estos o de que
lleguen al extremo de ser muy bajos y si
es muy bajo entonces rechazaremos la
hipótesis cero y en esa prueba como en
cualquier prueba de hipótesis
necesitamos un nivel de significación y
digamos que nuestro nivel de
significación es un 10% o un 0.1 que es
igual al 10% y ese es nuestro nivel de
significación ahora para hacer esto lo
que necesitamos hacer es calcular la
estadística y cuadrada para esta tabla
de contingencia y para hacerlo vamos a
realizar algo muy similar a la situación
del restaurante vamos a calcular
asumiendo la hipótesis 0 el resultado
esperado en cada una de estas celdas le
podemos llamar celda si estuviéramos
viendo esto como una tabla de excel cada
uno de esos cuadros sería una celda lo
que hacemos es calcular el valor
esperado
existiría si se cumple lo que asumimos
con la hipótesis cero si asumimos que la
hipótesis cero es la que se cumple
entonces tenemos que encontrar la
distancia al cuadrado de ese valor
esperado que hemos normalizado por el
valor esperado tomamos algunas de esas
diferencias y si esas diferencias al
cuadrado son realmente grandes la
probabilidad de que esto se cumpla sería
muy pequeña y por lo tanto rechazaríamos
esta hipótesis ahora veamos cómo podemos
obtener el número esperado asumiendo que
las hierbas no hacen nada entonces
debemos calcular de toda esta población
aquellos que no les ha pasado nada y
usar esa muestra de la población aunque
bueno no debería usar la palabra
población ya que esta es una muestra
para calcular el número esperado de
personas que se enferman o no se
enferman por acá tenemos a 80 de los 380
que están enfermos y algo acabo de usar
la palabra población no hemos tomado
muestras de todas las personas que
habitan en este planeta así que esto es
sólo una muestra sacamos la calculadora
aquí usa la palabra
son más en el sentido social que en el
sentido estadístico pero estas maneras
de nuestra muestra y estamos usando toda
la información y podemos usar toda la
información para obtener la frecuencia
esperada de los que se les forman y los
que no se enfermen tenemos 80 entre 380
y nos da punto 21 lo que significa que
el porcentaje de personas que se
enferman es de el 21 por ciento 21 por
ciento de los que si se enferman por lo
tanto esa parte va a ser el 79 por
ciento de las personas que no se
enferman así que nosotros esperaríamos
con base en la muestra total el 21 por
ciento debería enfermarse y el 79 por
ciento debería mantenerse sano
así que vamos a revisar cada uno de
estos grupos
si nosotros asumiéramos que el 21 por
ciento de estas 120 personas debería
enfermarse cuál sería el valor esperado
de acá vamos a multiplicar 21 por ciento
este 21% por 120 usamos la calculadora y
nos da 25 puntos 26 vamos a redondear lo
esperaremos el 25.3 así que el número
esperado
el valor esperado
asumiendo que el 21 por ciento de cada
uno de los grupos debe enfermarse
esperaremos el 25.3
de las personas que se enfermen en este
grupo y los que sobren no se deberán
enfermar así que ahora puedo restar 25.3
a 120 o multiplicar esto por el 79%
cualquiera de las 2 da lo mismo vamos a
hacer 120 menos 25.3 y tengo 94.7 94.7
son los que se espera que no se enfermen
el valor esperado esperado 94.7 y vamos
a hacer lo mismo para cada uno de estos
grupos para el grupo 2 tenemos tomamos
el total de 140 y obtenemos el 21% de
ello el resultado de el 21% de 140 es
29.4 el resto de esto vamos a restar 140
menos 29.4 es 110.6 de los que no se
deben enfermar lo escribimos en el
renglón de valores esperados 20
punto 4 que deberían enfermarse si las
hierbas no hicieran nada y aquí tenemos
110 puntos 6 los cuales no deberían
enfermarse si la hipótesis 0 es correcta
y esos valores pues están bastante
cercanos a los que tenemos en la tabla
de hecho pareciera que la hierba no hace
mucho dado el total de las cantidades
que tenemos aquí en el grupo placebo
vamos a ver que obtenemos tenemos 30 es
no esperamos 21 por ciento del total
punto 21 por ciento 20 y nos da 25.2 lo
anotamos en el valor esperado del grupo
del placebo aunque por aquí debía haber
redondeado esto porque ese es un 21
punto y tantos por ciento así que
deberíamos esperar la misma proporción
de las personas que se enferman 25.3
para que seamos consistentes la razón
por la que obtuve un 23.2 es que perdí
algo de la precisión en este porcentaje
pero ya que los tengo aquí los voy a
usar aquí también
en esta parte de acá vamos a esperar el
94.7 94.7
si revisamos esta información veremos
que la hierba 2 hasta cierto punto es
peor que el placebo no no no me
equivoqué
se esperaría un número más bajo si
tuviéramos más personas enfermas acá
pero bueno no vamos a juzgar bien no
solamente los números vamos a calcular
nuestras estadísticas de eje cuadrada
para hacer eso vamos a sacar nuestras
estadísticas nuestra estadística he
cuadrada la voy a escribir así y bueno
mejor así como una equis grande esta
variable de distribución aleatoria es
aproximada a la distribución y cuadrada
que voy a escribir así no mejor vamos a
escribir la equis curveada
así que nuestra estadística es cuadrada
así que nuestra estadística cuadrada por
acá vamos a encontrar la distancia al
cuadrado es decir la diferencia entre el
valor esperado y el valor observado y
después dividirlo entre la esperada 20 -
25.3 al cuadrado y después dividirlo
entre la esperada
25 puntos 3 más 30 menos 29.4 al
cuadrado / 29.4 y me he quedado sin
espacio más 30 menos 25.3 esto elevado
al cuadrado entre 25.3 y ahora
corresponde hacer lo mismo con los
valores de abajo y necesito hacer más
espacio
así que es más
100 - 94.7 al cuadrado entre 90 y 4.7
más y bueno ustedes ya pueden adivinar
lo que sigue
110 - 110.6 al cuadrado entre 110 puntos
6 y finalmente más 90 entre 90 y 4.7
perdón 90 menos 94.7 todo esto al
cuadrado vamos a movernos un poco al
cuadrado entre 90 y 4.7 y para calcular
todo esto vamos a necesitar nuestra
calculadora nos va a llevar algo de
tiempo pero no importa tenemos
vamos a poner paréntesis 20 - 25.3
elevado al cuadrado entre
25.3
esto más ahora paréntesis 30 menos 29.4
elevado al cuadrado entre 29.4
abrimos paréntesis 30 - 25.3 al cuadrado
/ ya saben 25.3
llamamos a la mitad más 100 menos abro
paréntesis 100 menos 94.7 al cuadrado
entre 90 y 4.7
as
abro paréntesis
110 - 610 puntos 6 al cuadrado dividido
en 3 110.6 el último más
90 - 94.7 al cuadrado
/ 94.7 vaya terminamos obtenemos 2.528
vamos a redondear las 2.53
así que nuestra estadística de la ji
cuadrada aunque es algo difícil de
pronunciar estadística de ji cuadrada
asumiendo que la hipótesis cero es
correcta va a ser igual a 2.53
y ahora tenemos que calcular los grados
de libertad que tenemos al calcular esta
estadística de jia cuadrado
y les daré una regla de oro y veremos
cuál es la razón de por qué esta es una
regla de oro para tablas de contingencia
como esta y más adelante hablaremos con
más detalle de los grados de libertad
esta regla de oro para las tablas de
contingencia es tener el número de
renglones y tenemos nuestro número de
columnas
tenemos dos renglones y tres columnas y
los grados de libertad y esta es la
regla de oro vamos a escribirlo aquí
abajo donde hay más espacio los grados
de libertad para la tanda de
contingencia van a ser el número de
renglones menos uno multiplicado por el
número de columnas menos una en este
caso tenemos dos renglones tres columnas
dos menos uno es igual a 13 menos 1 es
igual a 2 lo escribimos acá
2 - 1 por 3 menos 11 por 2 igual a 2 por
lo que tenemos dos grados de libertad
ahora veamos por qué esta regla tiene
sentido aunque en el futuro veremos esto
con más detalle es que si asumimos que
conocemos los totales
si conocemos toda esta información que
estoy sufriendo acá
si conocemos la información total o
incluso si conocemos los parámetros de
la población
si conocemos r - uno de la información
en los renglones la última puede
calcularse al restar la del total por
ejemplo en esta situación si conocemos
esto podremos calcular esto otro esto no
es información nueva
es el total menos la información que
conozco y lo mismo aplica en esta otra
columna si conozco este valor al restar
lo del total voy a obtener el valor de
acá y de manera similar si conocemos
estos dos podré calcular el tercer
elemento al restar lo que conozco del
total del renglón y esa es la razón de
por qué los grados de libertad están más
o menos en función del número de
columnas y de renglones de la tabla de
contingencia
así pues nuestra estadística de gi
cuadrada tiene dos grados de libertad
ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es bueno
recuerden que el nivel de significación
que queremos el valor de alfa es el 10%
lo vamos a recibir aquí abajo alfa igual
a 10% así que lo que vamos a hacer es
calcular cuál es la estadística cuadrada
crítica que nos da el 10% si esto
más al extremo si la probabilidad de
obtener esto fuera menos que la
estadística crítica menos del 10%
entonces rechazaríamos la hipótesis cero
si no es tan extrema entonces no vamos a
rechazar nuestra hipótesis lo siguiente
que vamos a hacer es encontrar nuestra
distribuciones y cuadrada con dos grados
de libertad y ver cuál es la estadística
cuadrada crítica
veamos nuestra gráfica encontramos dos
grados de libertad y estamos buscando un
nivel de significación del 10% y
encontramos que nuestro valor de
distribución y cuadrada es 4.60 otra
forma de visualizar esto es si vemos
esta distribución cuadrada con dos
grados de libertad que es esta línea de
color azul de acá con un valor crítico
que voy a dibujar aquí en un azul bonito
un valor crítico de 4.60
estos cinco entonces 4.60 va a estar más
o menos por acá en este valor crítico de
4.60 lo escribo la probabilidad de tener
algo al menos tal extremo o más extremo
aún es el 10% esto es lo que nos
interesa
si la estadística he cuadrada que
calculamos cae dentro de esta área de
rechazo pues tendremos que rechazar
nuestra hipótesis cero pero nos
estadística he cuadrado es de apenas dos
puntos 53 si lo vemos en nuestra gráfica
2.53 más o menos queda por acá así que
realmente no tiene nada de raro el
asumir que es verdadera nuestra
hipótesis 0 con base a la información
que tenemos actualmente no podemos
rechazar la hipótesis 0 y aunque no
sabemos a ciencia cierta que las hierbas
no hagan nada tampoco podemos decir que
hagan algo realmente con base al menos
en esta información por lo que no vamos
a rechazar esta hipótesis aunque no
podemos decir que esto es 100% verdadero
al menos desde este punto de vista vemos
que las hierbas al parecer no hacen gran
cosa y vemos que incluso una de estas
columnas es un placebo así que no hay
gran diferencia entre ellas